สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครู
หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีปีพ.ศ
2565  66
66 ครูหญิงเขียนถูกครูฟ้าพูดผิดครูฟ้า
พูดถูกครูหญิงเขียนผิดสลับกันไปนะคะแล้ว
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2223 นะคะค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่ง
นี้วันพุธวันวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้
เวลา 18:00 น
18:00 นหรือว่า 18:00 น 18:00 นค่ะอ่า 18
นนะคะหรือว่าคนไทย 1800 นกี่นาที
18  29 นาทีอื
1829 นาอีก 1 นาทีก็จะ 6:30 นแล้วนะคะ
18:00 นอุ้ยเราก็ต้องเริ่มหิวแล้วมาอ่ะ
18:30 นแล้วอ่ะหิวแล้วต้องกินข้าวแล้ว
ค่ะต้องกินอาหารเย็นแล้วโอหครูหญิงจะกิน
ข้าวเนี่ยจะกินอะไรคะครูฟ้าเออ
เนี่ยครูหญิงก็จะถามครูฟ้าเลยว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยคิดหรือยังว่าเย็นนี้จะกินอะไรดี
อือืเย็นนี้กินอะไรดีอืครูฟ้าอยากกินอัน
นี้ค่ะครูหญิงครูฟ้าอยากกินอะไรคะนัก
เรียนทุกๆวันนะคะตอนตอนเช้าเอ่อ 6:00 น
เนี่ยไม่เท่าไหร่นะคะอ่ะตอนเที่ยนตอนเย็น
เนี่ยตอนเที่นตอนเย็นเนี่ยครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าต้องนั่งคิดเอ๊กินอะไรดีนะกินอะไรใดี
นะเพราะว่าประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีอาหารเยอะมาก
ครูฟ้าจะกินอะไรคะคิดออกหรือยัง 1 เลยนะ
ครูฟ้าจะกินต้มยำกุ้งค่ะครูหญิงอ่าต้มยำ
กุ้งอืต้มยำกุ้งแล้วก็กินอะไรคะกินต้มยำ
กุ้งและกินอะไรไก่
ทอดไก่ทอดอันนี้เป็นไก่นะกะกระตากนะคะโหย
ครูฟ้าหมดหรือยังคะกินต้มยำกุ้งกินไก่ทอด
กินผัดไทยด้วยผัดไทยอุ๊ยอันนี้นักเรียน
น่าจะชอบนะคะผัดไทยอืแล้ว
ก็แล้วก็กินอะไรอีกค่ะูฟ้าเอ่อตยกุ้งไก่
ทอดผัดไทยเนี่ย 3 อย่างแล้วนะคุณกินคน
เดียวเหรอคะ 3 อย่างกินคนเดียวค่ะครูฟ้า
ไม่ไม่ให้ใครกินด้วยนะคะ
แล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงนะครูหญิงอยาก
กินแกงจืดอ๋อแกงจืดนี่เป็นซุปใช่มยซุป
เป็นต้มจืดอแกงจืดนะคะนี่ไงอยากกินอครู
ฟ้าแต่ว่าต้มยำกุ้งไก่ทอดผัดไทยแกงจืด
เนี่ยมันเป็นอาหารไทยที่แบบธรรมดาธรรมดา
มากๆ
แล้วอาหารไทยอะไรที่ไม่ธรรมดาลคะผู้หญิง
อ้าครูฟ้าคิดดูนะอันนี้ประเทศไทยใช่มยคะ
นักเรียนไม่ใช่สนูปี้นะคะภาคเหนือภาค
กลางภาค
อีสานแล้วก็ภาคใต้เนี่ย 4 ภาคเนี่ยมีต้ม
ยำกุ้งมีผัดไทยมีไก่โอดมีต้มจืดอธรรมดา
ค่ะครูฟ้าธรรมดา
ครูครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ประเทศไทยมา 27 ปีเป็น
คนไทย 27 ปีแล้วครูฟ้ากินแต่อาหารไทย
ธรรมดาเหรอคะครูฟ้าไม่คิดที่จะกินอาหาร
ไทยที่มันแบบแปลกๆเราเนี่ยไม่ได้
เห็นทุกวันเราไม่ใช่ไม่ได้เห็นทุกวันเนาะ
เราไม่ได้กินทุกวันเราไม่ได้เดินใช่มอัน
นี้เป็นถนนอืแล้วก็นี้เป็นฟุตบาตเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้เดินฟุตบาตแล้วก็เห็นว่า
โอ๊ครูฟ้าเดินฟุตบาตเนี่ยก็เห็นต้มยำกุ้ง
ผัดไทยไก่ทอดเดินฟุตบาตที่เชียงใหม่ก็ต้ม
ยำกุ้งผัดไทยไก่ทอดเดินฟุตบาที่ภูเก็ตตก็
ต้มยำกุ้งผัดไทยไก่ทอดเดินฟุตบาที่ภาค
อีสานก็ต้มย้ำกุ้งผัดไทยไก่ทอดเดินฟุตบา
ที่พัทยาต้มยอมกุ้งผัดไทยไข่ทอดธรรมดาค่ะ
ครูฟ้าแล้วครูหญิงจะให้ครูฟ้ากินอะไรอะไร
ที่แปลกๆเครูฟ้านี่ไงครูหญิงเนี่ยวัน
เนี้ยครูหญิงคิดว่ามีอาหารไทยที่มันเป็น
เมนูแปลกๆที่ไม่รู้ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยเห็น
เคยกินหรือเปล่าหรือว่านักเรียนเนี่ยเคย
เห็นไหมมแต่ถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนัก
เรียนอาจจะเคยเห็นนักเรียนก็คิด
เฮ้ยทำไมไม่เหมือนอาหารไทยที่อเมริกา
อาหารไทยที่ยุโรปที่ญี่ปุ่นมันแปลกไงครู
หญิงเนี่ยอยากกินอืูหญิงก็ไม่เคยก็เลย
อยากจะให้เอามาให้ครูฟ้าเอามาให้นักเรียน
ดูแล้วให้ครูฟ้ากับนักเรียนเนี่ยดู
ว่าอยากกินมยหรือว่าครูฟ้าอาจจะเคยกิน
หรือเปล่าก็ไม่รู้นะอุ๊ย
อาหารไทยแปลกๆอย่างงั้นเหรอคะครูไฟอยาก
รู้แล้วค่ะครูหญิง
ว่ามันคืออะไรโหจริงๆอาหารไทยแปลกๆมีเยอะ
มากนะคะแต่ครูหญิงเอาแบบแปลกแบบปกติอ่ะ
ไม่ใช่แปลกแบบเลเวลมากๆนะคะเอ่าอ่ะมีหลาย
เลเวลด้วยนะคะหลายเลเวลค่ะครูฟ้านี่ค่ะ
อย่างแรกเลยครูฟ้าเห็นไหมอันนี้คืออะไร
เนี่ยตัว
อะไรตัวเ็กมากกุ้งค่ะครูหญิงใช่ค่ะกุ้งดู
สิในจานนี้เนี่ยกุ้งบางตัวเนี่ยมันยัง
กระโดดอยู่เลยเห็น
มยกุ้งยังไม่ตายหรอใช่ค่ะอันนี้ ste
alive กุ้งกำลังเต้นอยู่เมนูนี้เนี่ยนะ
คะชื่อว่ากุ้งเต้นกุ้งอันนี้กุ้งใช่มั้ย
กุ้งกุงเต้นเลคิ dis  love อันนี้กุ้ง
เต้นใช่มั้ยคะเ้นค่ะมันชื่อว่ากุ้งเต้น
เพราะว่ากุ้งเนี่ยมันยังไม่ตายไงมันยัง
กระโดดดึ๋งดึ๋เหมือนมันเต้นเหมือนมันเต้น
นะก็เลยเรียกชื่อว่ากุ้งเต้นหืครูหญิง
แล้วมันจะกินยังไงกุ้งเต้นเนี่ยหกินได้
แล้วในจานเนี้ยทำเสร็จแล้วแต่ว่าอ่ะห้ะ
อุ๊ยอะไรคะไปไหนอ่ะคะอ้าอุ๊ยกุ้งหายนะคะ
นักเรียนขอโทษด้วยนะคะอ่ะกลับมาแล้วอืม
นี่ไงครูฟ้าเห็นมั้ยเนี่ยว่าตัวกุ้งมัน
ยังแบบใสๆอยู่เลย
อ่ะนี่ไงกุ้งเนี่ยมันว่ายน้ำอยู่ในน้ำใช่
มั้ยคะนักเรียนเาก็เอาตะแกรงเนี่ยช้อน
กุ้งขึ้นมากุ้งยังไม่ตายนะกุ้งยังหายใจ
อยู่นะคะเนี่ยแล้วก็เอามาใส่่ที่กะละมัง
แล้วก็บีบอันเนี้ยคือมะนาวนะคะนักเรียน
มะนาว
ค่ะมะนาวเปรี้ยวๆบีบใส่ใส่พริกเห็นมยแล้ว
ก็คลุกุกุกๆให้เข้ากันแล้วก็ออกมาเป็น
กุ้งเต้นเหมือนซาชิมิมยครูฟ้ากินซาชิมิ
มั้ยซาชิมิซาชิมิซูซาชิมิปลลาแซแซลมอนใช่
มมีแซลมอนใช่ชอบกินแซลมอนใช่มยแซลมอน
เนี่ยก็ยังดิบๆยังไม่สุกไม่ได้เอาไปต้ม
ไม่ได้เอาไปผัดครูฟ้าก็กินได้เนี่ยกุ้ง
เต้นก็เหมือนกันอืก็คือเป็นกุ้งดิบๆนะคะ
นักเรียนกุ้งยังไม่ตายครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเป็นคน
ไทยเนี่ยครูหญิงต้องถามก่อนว่าครูฟ้าเคย
กินกุ้งเต้นมยเคยกิน
มยทำหน้าแบบนี้แปลว่าอะไรคิดว่าครูฟ้าเคย
กินกุ้งเต้นมยคะเออแต่ครูหญิงคิดว่าไม่
เคยนะเพราะพอครูหญิงเปิดมาให้ดูเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าก็ทำหน้าแบบหึอะไรครูหญิงก็เลยคิดว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่เคย
กินครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
คะเคยกินกุ้งเต้นค่ะครูฟ้าเคยกินกุ้งเต้น
ครูฟ้ากินกุ้งเต้นตอนอายุเท่าไหร่ตอนนี้
ครูฟ้าอายุ 27 ใช่ไหมตอนนี้เนาะอันนี้
อ้าว
2023 ค่ะแล้วครูฟ้ากินกุ้งเต้นเนี่ยอายุ
เท่าไหร่เมื่อไหร่ครูฟ้ากินกุ้งเต้นตอน
อายุ 20 เออไปเขียนอะไรตรงนั้น 20 ไม่
เป็นไรมันคิดว่านจะ 21 ไม่ใช่ 20 ด้วย 21
ตอนครูฟ้าอายุ 21 ครูฟ้ากินใช่มั้ยตอน
อายุ 21 ครูฟ้ากินกุ้งเต้นอืตอนนั้นครู
ฟ้าคิดอะไรตอนครูฟ้ากินเข้าไปตักกุ้งเต้น
แล้วก็เอาข้าวป่าแล้วก็
เคี้ยวนักเรียนคะอร่อยมยครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
เป็นคนกินกุ้งครูฟ้าเป็นกุ้งเลอร์นะคะครู
ฟ้าชอบกินกุ้งมากๆนะคะแล้วครูฟ้าก็กิน
ราชิมิกุ้ง
ด้วยจริงหรอแบบว่ามันก็ไม่ใช่ทรายชิมิ
กุ้งสิมันเป็นกุ้งแบบเดี๋ยวเปิดให้ดูอ๋อ
กุ้งแช่น้ำปลามยใช่อ่าแต่อันนั้นมันจะ
เป็นกุ้งกุ้งที่อยู่ที่ทะเลไงอันนั้นมัน
เป็นกุ้งทะเลใช่นี่นักเรียนปกติครูฟ้ากิน
กุ้งแบบนี้เนี่ยนะคะอืเห็นมยเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยกุ้งใช่มยแล้วูเก็ชอบมากนะคะฟ้า
ก็เลยแต่นั้นมันเป็นกุ้งแต่นั้นมันเป็น
กุ้งทะเลครูฟ้าเนี่ยกุ้งทะเลแต่กุ้งเต้น
เนี่ยมันเป็นกุ้งแม่
น้ำค่ะ
แต่มันก็คือกุ้ง
อ๋อครูฟ้าชอบกินกุ้งทั้งหมดนะคะูฟ้าก็เลย
เห็นกุ้งเต้นแล้วก็คิดครูฟ้าจะกินกุ้ง
เต้นแล้วครูฟ้าก็เห็นเค้าเนี่ยเอากุ้ง
ขึ้นมาใส่พริกใส่มะนาวแล้วก็แบบนี้ใช่มย
ใช่แล้วก็เสิร์ฟให้ครูฟ้านักเรียนกุ้งยัง
แบบกระโดดกระโดดแล้วมันกระโดดดึ๋งๆดึ๋ๆ
ดึ๋ๆครูฟ้าก็เลยคิดครูฟ้าไม่อยากกินกุ้ง
ที่ไม่ตายนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้ากลัวนิดหน่อย
ก็เลยรอครูฟ้าก็นั่งรอ
อ๋ออ 1 ชมงให้กุ้ง
ตาย
ใช่คือพอ 1 ชมงแล้วเนี่ยกุ้งมันก็ไม่
กระโดดแล้วใช่มยแบบเนี้ยอืกระโดดเนี่ยไม่
แล้วมันเริ่มแบบเผ็ดเผ็ดแล้วก็เปรี้ยว
หรือเปล่าใช่ค่ะแล้วกุ้งมันก็จะตายนะคะ
โดนมะนาวไงอืแต่ว่านักเรียนคะอันนี้
เนี่ยเป็นยังไงคะอร่อย
มากอร่อยใช่มยพอครูฟ้ารอกินเข้าไปแล้วแบบ
หืถ้าครูหญิงมีกุ้งเต้นแล้วก็เอามาให้ครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้นะเนี่ย
223 เนี่ยให้กุ้งเต้นครูฟ้า 1 จานครูฟ้า
เนี่ยยิ้มอยากลองเอ่อไม่ใช่อยากลองนะครู
ฟ้ากินแล้วครูฟ้ากินได้อืค่ะอร่อยมากอ่ะ
ตุ้งเต้นน่ะอือืนะคะอ่าค่ะดีกอ่อยใช่ค่ะ
อ่านั่นแหละเนาะก็เป็นกุ้งเต้นนะคะถ้านัก
เรียนมาแล้วเห็นอันนี้ที่เดินฟุตบาตแล้ว
เห็นก็อาจจะกินเพราะว่ารู้จักแล้วนะคะ
อืโอเคมยคะอ่ะกลับมาแล้วนะคะค่ะค่ะ
โอเคต่อไปอันนี้กุ้งเต้นเนาะอ่า
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเห็นครูหญิงมั้ยคะเห็นค่ะครู
หญิงโอเคครูฟ้าเห็นอาหารจานนี้เนี่ยเมนู
นี้ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอีขาวๆขาวๆขาวๆเนี่ยหรือ
ว่าเมนูนี้เนี่ยคืออะไรครูฟ้ารู้
มยอันนี้เนี่ยนะคะก็คือครูฟ้ารู้จักมั้ย
รู้ค่ะ
จริงๆครูหญิงเอามาก็ไม่แปลกสำหรับครูฟ้า
สิแต่มันก็แปลกอยู่นะอือะไรคะครูฟ้าครู
ฟ้ารู้จักไข่มด
แดงถูกต้องค่ะนักเรียนอันนี้เนี่ยนะคะนัก
เรียนเห็นมย
อเนี่ยอันเนี้ยคือมดแดงนะคะนักเรียนมัน
ไม่รู้ว่ารูปไหนจะเห็นชัดอ่ะเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยมดแดงนะคะมดแดงอ่าอเหมือนกันนะ
เนี่ยมดใช่มยมดออแล้วก็อันนี้ก็คือไข่มด
แดงเหมือนไก่อ่ะ
เนาะใช่มยไก่เนี่ยป๊อกๆๆไก่เก็มีไข่ใช่มย
อันนี้ไข่ไก่นะคะแต่อันนี้เนี่ยคือไข่มด
แดงแต่ว่ามันน่าจะเหมือนไม่รู้อ่ะเอออ่ะ
ครูฟ้ารู้จักว่ามันคือไข่มดแดงไข่มดแดง
ค่ะใช่แล้วก็เมนูจริงๆไข่มดแดงเนี่ยทำได้
หลายๆเมนูนะคะเอาไปต้มทำเป็นซุปก็ได้นะคะ
แต่อนี้น่าจะเป็นยำไข่มดแดงอุ๊ยยังมีมด
อยู่เลยอ่ะ
เนี่ยโอใช่อันนี้ก็มีมดครูหญิงคิดว่าเ้า
ใส่ทั้งหมดเลยแบบนี้หรือเปล่าอ่ะใส่ทั้ง
หมดค่ะอ่าครูฟ้ายำไข่มดแดงเนี่ยครูฟ้าเคย
กินมย
ต้องบอกก่อนนะคะนักเรียนว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่ชอบมดสุดๆถ้าเกิดในอาหารมีมดูฟ้าก็จะ
เอามด
ออกเราไม่กินมดไงเราก็ต้องหยิบออกครูฟ้า
แบบว่าซีเรียสกับมดบ้านะคะไม่เอามดเลยนะ
คะถ้ามีมดตัวเล็กๆ 1 ตัวครูฟ้าก็เอา
ออกอือแต่ยำไข่มดแดงเนี่ยมดเต็มเลยครู
หญิงหไม่เนี่ยนี่ก็มดเนี่ยูหญิคิดว่านี่
ก็มดนี่ก็น่าจะมดเปล่ามดๆอันนี้ก็อืม
เนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
คะเคยกินค่ะเคยกิน
อ๋อคือครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่เคยกินนะคะไม่เคย
กินอ่ะกุ้งเต้นเนี่ยเมนูที่แล้วเนี่ยกุ้ง
เต้นเนี่ยครูหญิงเคยกินนะถ้าให้ครูหญิง
กินอีกโอเคอร่อยนะคะแต่ยำไข่มดแดงเนี่ย
ครูหญิงไม่เคยกินแต่ก็อยากลองไงแบบอุ้ย
มันแปกอ่ะมันไม่มีแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยกิน
ครูฟ้าอายุเท่าไหร่คะกินไข่มดแดงตอนไหน
น่าจะอายุ 20  3 ปีโอโหอายุ 21 กินกุ้ง
เต้นนะคะอายุ 20  1 กินไข่มดแดงแล้วตอน
ที่มีคนเนี่ยเอาไข่มดแดงมาแล้วก็บอกฟ้า
อ่ะลองกินไข่มดแดงแล้วครูฟ้าเห็นตอนนั้น
ครูฟ้าคิดอะไรอ่ะรู้สึกแบบ
อีแปลกคือว่าแบบโอเคนะก็อยากลองครูฟ้าคิด
ว่าครูฟ้าอยากลองนะคะไข่มดแดงเนี่ยอือแต่
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบมดฟ้าก็จะเอามดออกแล้ว
ก็ลองกินไข่มดแดงไปนิดหน่อยยังไงคะเวลา
ครูฟ้ากินเข้าไปแล้ว
เคี้ยวมันเป็นยังไงอ่ะมันเปรี้ยวมั้ย
เพราะว่ามดเนี่ยนะคะมดแดงอย่างเงี้ยเนาะ
เนี่ยมดอย่างเงี้ยหรือว่ามดแดงที่นัก
เรียนเห็นแบบเนี้ยมันจะมีความเหมือน
เปรี้ยวมั้ยแล้วผู้หญิงรู้ได้ยังไงคะมด
เปรี้ยวเออมันมันรสชาติเป็นยังไงอ่ะครู
ฟ้าไอ้ไข่มดแดงแบบเนี้ยรชาติเหมือแบบ
มีค่ะมีรสชาตินะคะแต่คฟ้ามันเหมือนมัน
เหมือนเจเจลลอ่ะมันจะเป็นเจลเจลเป็น
เยลลี่อ๋อแบบเหมือนเยลลี่หนุบเออนิดนึงนะ
คะแล้วก็ก็โอเคแหละก็โอเคแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
คิดมดมดๆๆดๆเวลากินูฟ้ามดหมดเวลาเวลากิน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ได้คิดตรงนี้ใช่ไหมไข่แต่
ครูฟ้าคิดฉันกินมฉันกินมดฉันกิน
มดผูพระเนี่ยไม่ชอบมดนะคะไซโคตัวเองมด
เหรอมดปาก็เลยกลัวยำไข่มดนิดหน่อยออือก็
แต่เหมือนผู้หญิงรู้สึกว่ายำไข่มดแดงบาง
ครั้งถ้าให้นักเรียนเลือกใช่มยำไข่มดแดง
หรือว่ากุ้งเต้นู้หญิงคิดว่านักเรียนน่า
จะเลือกยำไข่มดแดงนะใชู่ฟ้าก็คิดว่าอย่าง
งั้นนะนักเรียนมันอร่อยนะมันโอเคอ่ะนะนัก
เรียนลองกินนะก็โอเคแต่ครูฟ้านี่ไม่ชอบมด
ไงยำไข่มดแดงเนี่ยราคาแพงด้วยนะแพงนะคะ
นักเรียนเพราะว่าไข่มดเนี่ย 1 กกรเนี่ยู้
หูไม่รู้อ่ะครุหญิงคิดว่าแพงมากกว่าหมูอื
ใช่มั้ยหมูหมูเนี่ยถูกกว่าเพราะว่าไข่มด
แดงมันมีน้อยไงมันไม่ได้กินได้ทั้ง 12
เดือนใช่มยคะไม่ได้ไงมันต้องมีเวลาเวลา
ไหนมีไข่มดแดงนะคะแต่ถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศ
ไทยอันนี้ก็เป็นถือว่าคนไทยก็ยังคิดว่า
มันแปลกนะคะแปลก
อืแล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงอันนี้ไม่เอาดีกว่านะ
คะอันนี้เนี่ยคิดว่านักเรียนน่าจะรู้จัก
มากที่สุดใน 3 เมนูที่เราเอามาให้ดูที่
เป็นอาหารแกของไทย
อืออันนี้คืออะไรอันนี้คือแมลงทอดนะคะนัก
เรียนมันก็จะมี 2 อันนี้เนี่ยเป็นหนอน
เนาะเป็นหนอนนะคะคุณหญิงไม่รู้พดูมีใคร
กลัวหนอนมั้ยแบบเอิ่มอะไรนะ disclaimer
ไว้ก่อนนะคะนักเรียนว่ามีหนอนนะต่อจากนี้
นะคะนี่เนาะมีหนอนเนี่ยมีหนอนอันนี้แล้ว
ก็ที่อยู่ในนี้เนี่ยที่มันอยู่ในนี้แล้ว
เนี่ย
อ่ะสมมุติเอาให้ดูนะอันนี้ 1 มั้งเอไม่
ใช่นะไม่เหมือนกันมั้งอันนี้น่าจะเป็นอัน
นี้มั้ง 2 เนี่ยน่าจะเป็นอันนี้นะคะเนี่ย
เป็นหนอนนะค่ะนักเรียนเป็นหนอนนะอันเนี้ย
หนอนหนอนนะคะเขาก็เอามาทอดเนาะมีกระทะใช่
มั้ยคะใส่น้ำ
มันติดไฟแล้ว
ก็เอาไปทอดนะคะอันนี้เป็นหนอนแล้วก็ 1  2
3  4 เนี่ยเป็นแมลงนะครูหญิงรู้แต่อัน
นี้นะอันที่ 4 เนี่ยก็คืออันนี้อตั๊
กระแตนนะคะเป็นตั๊กกระแตนทอดอืแต่จริงๆ
อันนี้อร่อยนะนักเรียนผู้หญิงเคยกินเหรอู
หญิงเคยกินครูหญิงเคยกินตั๊กแตนนะคะแต่
ว่าไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ตั๊กแตนทอดแบบนี้ครูหญิง
เคยกินตั๊กแตนบาร์บีคิวูหญิงทำเองนะคะโอน
recipe นะคะนักเรียนครูหญิงทำเองเคยกิน
ตั๊กแตนแต่ 1  2  3 อันนี้คุหญิงไม่เคยนะ
คะครูฟ้าแมลงทอดครูฟ้าไม่เคยกินใช่มยไม่
เคยหรือว่าเคยกินครูฟ้าไม่เคยกินแมลงทอด
เลยค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าไม่เคยใช่เหมือนกับ
มดอ่ะครูฟ้าไม่ชอบแมลงว่ากลัวแมลงเออๆ
เนาะอันนี้ก็เป็นหนอนหนอนเสร็จแล้วมันก็
เป็นแงเหมือนกันเนี่ยนักเรียนมันก็เป็น
แมลงถ้าครูฟ้าเแล้วครูหญิงบอกว่าอ่ะครู
ฟ้าลองครูฟ้าอยากลองมยแบบโอเคหรือ
ว่าไม่
เอาไม่เอาไม่ค่ะครูว่าจะไม่กินแมลงไม่ว่า
กลัวแมลงอ่ะแล้วก็ไม่กินผู้หญิงเหมือนกัน
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยอันนี้เราเรียกด้วงนะคะนัก
เรียนด้วงหนอน
ไม่เอานะคะู้หญิงเห็นแล้ว
อุ้ยทำไมคะเป็นอะไรนักหนาคะครูหญิงเห็น
แล้วนะ
คะคิดถึงอันเนี้ย
เกินไม่ได้กลัวใช่ไหมเออนะกลัวนะคะแต่ว่า
อันนี้ก็เป็นอาหารไทยที่แปลกๆนะจริงๆยัง
มีอีกเยอะแต่ครูหญิงเอามาให้นักเรียนดู 3
อย่างเนาะมีแมลงทอดอันนี้ไม่เอานะคะ
ยำไข่มดแดงเนาะแล้วก็กุ้งเต้นนะคะนัก
เรียนอยากลองกินเมนูไหนเมนูที่ 1 กุ้ง
เต้นเมนูที่ 2 ยำไข่มดแดงหรือว่าเมนูที่ 3
แมลงทอดก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะแต่วีดีโอ
นี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วีีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะจบ
ด้วยแมลงทอดนะคะ